hi so i'm extremely uh happy and
grateful to be here today with sandy
ronnie who's our new associate director
welcome sandy thank you it's really
wonderful to be here and to be back in a
more permanent role here in berkeley
and in fact you were a graduate student
at berkeley during the 80s we did not
overlap i think i left a year before you
arrived exactly so i am senior to you
yes forever i i miss the glory years of
your time here so
i'm just joking
we had our own glory years though so
yeah so tell so you're coming you were
graduate berkeley and uh anything to say
about those times
um
it was wonderful i mean i felt like a
whole new world opened up to me when i
came here as a graduate student and it
was an incredible community
i remember walking in
the first day to dick carp's course on
concrete complexity theory and the room
was packed not just with students but
with post docs and visitors and other
faculty i mean the the
excitement was really palpable and um
they stayed for the semester it was
great so um
i really kind of felt right away that i
was part of something special it was it
was a wonderful time here do you want an
undergraduate in princeton if i remember
yeah and what made you decide to come to
berkeley to study theoretical computer
science so
i always loved math in high school
um my dad didn't want me to major in
math because he thought i wouldn't get a
job afterwards so i ended up as a double
e major at princeton
and i kept calling home and saying
where's the math i'm not getting the
math so i eventually stumbled into
a course on automata theory which i like
very much
and then a friend of mine at princeton
said he was going to take a graduate
class from this new guy named bob tarjan
who had just come to princeton from bell
labs
and bob taught this course off of his
beautiful little monograph on data
structures and network algorithms and
that kind of sealed the deal for me i
really loved that class and then it was
it then i knew that's what i wanted to
do
i applied to a bunch of graduate schools
and i got into berkeley nyu and colombia
and i kind of wanted to stay in the new
york area because all my friends were
going to be there and i i
didn't visit berkeley um grad visit days
weren't a thing back then um but i went
to nyu in colombia and i was chatting
with the some of the professors there
and so this was 35 years ago not a
reflection of the current state of
affairs but i remember talking to one of
the theory faculty and mentioning in
passing i had gotten into berkeley and
he stopped short and he said oh you got
into berkeley well you need to go to
berkeley and that was it that was it so
that's how i ended up going to berkeley
so i see i see such parallels between
our stories you know first of all you
mentioned your dad
who um
it sort of seems to be instrumental in
the beginning at least telling you well
you should get a job yeah go to double e
say not into math and um i don't think
my father was as uh
knowledgeable about the intricate uh
differences but he definitely was a big
push uh let's say in high school i
wanted to do literature and uh he said
well you have to go to the math because
you know that's where you get the big
jobs and that's very pragmatic yeah and
uh but you know this image of him uh
believing in me but also pushing me
forward is very strong and the other
thing about getting into a few places
and not really thinking that berkeley is
the first choice yeah yeah also for me
it was i was actually decided to go
somewhere else and then i drove up the
coast
and i just go to visit and i took
university ave and and then i saw those
blue hills
and uh actually green hills and those
guys and i was like uh this is the place
right yeah very um spontaneous yeah a
bit impulsive um
so uh
in fact you started with algorithms so
this interest that you had in bob
tarzian's course and then dick carp
continued throughout your
years yeah so i spent most of my uh
career working in online algorithms with
sort of a an applied bent sort of
problems inspired by computer systems
memory management scheduling
power management strategies
um and then
12 15 years ago i needed to do something
different so i
started
taking classes and learning quantum at
that point
and i made the switch eventually and
started working and doing research in
quantum so it was a big change a lot of
different mathematical tools i needed to
develop and you know i wasn't a spring
chicken anymore at that point but um
it's been very rewarding it's been a lot
of fun so i think it's rewarding anyway
to make a switch absolutely
just the switch itself yeah usually you
make them more by epsilons than a big
leap but um
it's been a very also very exciting time
in uh research and quantum computing too
so i feel like i made a good choice and
when you finish berkeley you went
directly to irvine or did you go for a
postdoc i had the job at uci and then i
deferred it for a year and did a year of
post-doc and i spent part of the year on
the east coast and part of the year in
at ucsd
and uh now you are your permanent
position is in in uc irvine but we are
extremely lucky that you're moving here
yes we are associate director but you
still maintain a home at irvine yeah so
i'll be uh community up weekly and back
home for the weekends and i'm on leave
from uci so um but it's wonderful to be
back up here for the work week and i
feel like a graduate student again
because it's really feels like home turf
to me now
it's very interesting you know when i
decided to come from mit i really what i
envisioned was that i was a graduate
student again yeah uh
except you know uh with a little bit
more money so i understand that you've
rented an apartment yeah i have a little
place on the north side it's very nice
um better conditions than when a grad
school much better conditions so nicer
place i've moved up in the world a
little bit since then so that's good
yeah since i think it's like 30 years 30
yeah i graduated in 91 so yeah something
was something of the sort um so i know
that you actually uh besides berkeley
itself you were actually a program
organizer at simon's institute
uh for this quantum cluster so you know
the workings as an organizer any
any memories from that cluster or how it
worked it was an interesting experience
to be part of the planning i worked
closely with umesh in the process
and
i think the thing that i've learned from
that experience is watching umesh work a
little bit is that a little bit of
curating goes a long way so just
thinking in advance about how best to
connect people how much structure to
have how much programming they have how
to do whiteboard talks to
you know
to spark a discussion
a little bit of advanced planning along
those lines goes a long way and also in
sort of
you know people are coming from
different fields you've got physicists
and chemists and computer scientists and
talking to them a little bit in advance
so that they know
things that they might take for granted
that everyone knows they need to explain
so um a little bit of advanced planning
can go a long way in helping people
connect when they actually get to the
program so yeah that's true there was a
lot of experimentation even in the
pro in you know i think in all the
programs that russia was part of which
were all
dedicated to quantum computing in how to
run the boot camp say yeah to run them
in a stretch when they divide them over
a few weeks yes uh how much space to
give to interaction versus you know
frontal yeah yeah
so i hope that you can actually that's
an interesting thing to experiment
throughout all the programs i think so
um you know i think one of the wonderful
things about simon's is that it brings
people together and helps them connect
and collaborate and
you know
simon says a great track record in doing
that but i think we can always be
experimenting and sort of pushing the
boundaries to see how we can do that
better absolutely absolutely and i don't
i'm a firm believer that not everything
doesn't work for everyone i mean they're
in fact different formats and you have
to figure out what the dynamics of the
group are some groups are very cohesive
some groups haven't known each other
before right and you need
other formats to connect them and you
need to be a little bit nimble even
within the scope of a program if
something isn't working you got to
change it up and
make it so that it works a little better
so i'm really happy that you're thinking
about all these sort of different
ways to make this place uh better yeah
so for example in the summer cluster
that we just had on quantum
uh
chiang mai narcan had the idea of just
having a one day
spontaneous workshop around a set of
topics we planned it
a few days in advance and it was a big
success and that will actually serve
potentially as a model for some of the
things we'll do in the future quantum
programs
so
moving away from just quantum but
generalizing to the rest of the
institute uh what are your sort of
aspirations as uh
as an associate director it's an
interesting question to ask which
the reason i'm saying is because you
would think that that's the first
question you ask yourself but i think it
isn't
often no
yeah well
i think it's important to come into a
new place without too much of a
well-formed agenda i mean when i've
taken on administrative roles such as
department chair and others i've been a
part of the organization so i kind of
knew it quite well i'm coming in here
and i'm seeing simon's for the first
time from the inside
so
it's an assignments is a very
one-of-a-kind type of place so my job
for a little while is just to listen and
learn just to understand what's going on
and to to to get a sense of how things
work
but that being said i think
um like we talked about i think there's
a lot of room for innovation in terms of
um how we run programs how we get people
to connect within those programs but
then also how we communicate how we can
better sort of reach people outside of
theory um and how we can sort of
uh make that a more effective tool too
so i mean science has a lot of resources
like the writers and residents and all
kinds of different moving parts and how
we can
use those even more effectively i think
sounds wonderful and i in fact i think
one of the biggest challenges that both
the associate director and the director
should pay attention to is how to reach
a wider audience within sort of the real
computer science engineering mathematics
sciences anybody that can benefit from
the idea of computation and algorithms
to come here yes to come here and i
think it's also good for us to think
about
how to communicate that what's important
to us what are you know what are the
important burning questions in our field
too so that's sort of a good exercise
for any field to go through but um i
think the more we communicate the more
it will become sort of a magnet for
people from different fields and
and we'll have more even more
collaboration
and um
you know it's a kind of uh question of
the times
a
our mission is not just to
do
a wide reach to other sciences but also
a wide reach within
issues of gender and ethnicity
and different economic and
socio-economic uh
groups to broaden
you know the reach of computer science
the reach of algorithms any thoughts on
that and the role that you observe all
kinds of different ways to approach that
i mean
the most basic is just in terms of being
very intentional about who we invite who
we encourage to apply who we bring
inside and and encouraged to participate
in the program so that's
i mean you have to get people in the
room to order to have that kind of
inclusiveness
but also once people get here i think
you can also do a lot to help people
connect some people are more extroverted
as scientists than others and some you
know i think as a program organizer you
can facilitate more people connecting
with each other and being a part of
things so i think being a little bit
more proactive in that space is i think
will be also helpful
but also the communications i think
there's a lot of room there for reaching
a broader
general audience and
getting people excited about theoretical
computer science
which i think will then sort of help the
pipeline because that's also where the
problem starts it's true yeah uh one of
the most useful um
exercises for me when i was thinking
about uh what i want out of simon's
institute to look like was to think of
sort of aha moments that i've had during
my
own career
and what excited me about uh
you know what i'm doing or computer
science or a particular field within
theoretical computer science can you
sort of just
remember aha moment for you
um
i think when i was first you know for me
when i was first getting into quantum it
was all very mysterious i mean i had
trouble reading those papers i you know
i was sitting in a silo in at uci sort
of trying to understand this field from
a distance and reading course notes and
things
um
you know it was
really exciting for me the first time i
was able to understand research paper
and then actually prove some type of
result about something and just the idea
that
there was this marriage of
or this connection between really
fundamental problems in physics and
computational complexity and they have a
connection to each other
was really absolutely fascinating for me
that the complexity can inform the
physics and the physics can inform you
know computing was really exciting and i
think complexity is sort of continuing
to play a really important role in
in
quantum computation in all kinds of
different ways so that that was an
exciting discovery for me
yeah i could see that did you actually
study physics in high school in houston
no
i mean i was an engineer so there's a
required
physics you know intro course that i
took but i didn't have any special
education or background in it so it was
a deliberate decision that you wanted to
study quantum computing because it
seemed like an interesting field yes
yeah and i started by just sitting in on
a class in
physical chemistry just because i had
never learned what this quantum
mechanics thing was i just kind of was
curious about it so i wasn't actually
intending to go into quantum computing
at that point but once i started
learning more it was kind of an amazing
revelation to me i mean you start with
all of these sort of basic abstract
principles and by the end of the quarter
you've derived the orbitals that you
learn about you know in in high school
chemistry i thought that was pretty
amazing so um
so then you know i started doing more
reading and quantum computing and it and
then i got kind of hooked on it so
you've also written a book
can you tell us about that um it's a
zybook so it's i wrote it in
collaboration with a company called
cybooks.com
and
it's a web-based interactive textbook
unlike many attempts at sort of making
textbooks online where they just port
the material into the web
this was sort of created from scratch
with the platform in mind so
um the the tagline is less text more
action so it's very succinct but there
are lots of animations and interactive
exercises the topic uh discrete math so
i taught it with my uci students in mind
because i thought it would be a great
tool for them to learn um especially the
animation so much of that material is
dynamic so i thought it would be great
great as a teaching tool um and i'm just
delighted at how much it's caught on so
you know uh
40 000 students used my textbook last
year which is really cool so there's
like it's really it's easy catching on
in a way that i never expected so oh
that's incredible that's 40 000 critics
yeah
and they all have a way of clicking and
commenting on things so we get a lot of
feedback from that because it's all you
know all on the web so
interesting so uh some of the reaction
um that i
that i think we both get is that isn't
it cool uh at least that's the reaction
i get that we're both women
in this position and the reason that i
this question occurred to me just this
right now is because i was thinking
about the idea of 40 000 critics and
that um course evaluations and
evaluations yeah um from my experience
i've often heard
from uh
[Music]
women faculty members that that
experience is a little bit uh
traumatic at times yeah but apparently
not for you
i love teaching and i think i get along
pretty well with the students
i everybody i do this all the time when
i get my teaching evaluations there can
be 99 positive comments and i lock in on
the one negative one and it bugs me for
a week afterwards so i think there's a
little bit of perspective going on here
but you know i get a lot of energy from
teaching i and i enjoy teaching
unlike many of my colleagues i enjoy
teaching the freshmen and sophomores
they're eager to be there they're
excited i feel like i have a hand in
helping them stay in the program
sometimes
so i feel like i have a chance to really
kind of form their experience at uci so
i've always enjoyed it that's fantastic
yeah
um i guess uh i just wanted to ask you
also
um about tcs
more generally okay you know it has
evolved quite a bit from our time at
berkeley and
it's you know infiltrated many other
fields and other fields and applications
rather than just basic curiosity driven
research that come into our field any
sort of thoughts about how this
evolution occurred
i remember when i graduated
you know there weren't a lot of options
as to what you would do afterwards you
would get an academic job or you would
might go work for ibm research which
operated much at that point like an
academic unit so
or you would just go into industry and
do something unrelated to what you did
as in your phd so those were kind of the
options and it's expanded a lot since
then and now there are so many
opportunities to work in industry
and bounce back and forth in a way that
you're really sort of using your
theoretical expertise but contributing
you know in a tangible way to the
company
quantum right now is at a very exciting
time in terms of this interplay between
industry and academia there because it's
so new and it's so early
there's there's a lot of uh connections
between the two people you know
our theory colleagues are going off and
starting startups and people are
consulting with google and ibm and
microsoft and their efforts there so
there's just a very tight connection
which is particularly exciting in this
field but
i expect that to grow and continue as
people you know sort of
as as our ideas sort of infiltrate more
and have more of an influence and people
realize how important it is to have a
a good foundation to algorithms yeah
absolutely i find that one of the big
challenges and opportunities as well is
to explain how
uh basic science on its own uh or what
they call you know curiosity driven
science it has
remarkable outcomes but they are not
predictable and therefore you've got to
have sort of uh stamina and put your
faith in the fact that they're excellent
people and that this
ideas the basic foundations are
intriguing and let's see what develops
um without necessarily in the media yeah
and sometimes it takes time
it always takes time in my opinion you
know to make a real impact it always
takes time if you knew where you're
heading then what's the point of going
there yeah um
in research at least yes perhaps in life
it's different yeah but in research if
you know exactly what the answer is then
you are more in the realm of that's not
as interesting a question so
yeah that's not an interesting question
it's probably a lot more painful to get
there yeah but the reward is worth it
yeah that's true so uh wow it's i'm so
glad you're here i'm very glad to be
here
and uh i know it's gonna be a little
tough commuting but maybe it also allows
you a little bit of freedom yeah it's
it's kind of energizing in a way to be
in a different place in a different
space so i i'm looking forward to that
i'm looking forward to also
collaborating with people here in terms
of my research
so i think it's going to be good for
that as well so um i think there are a
lot of good things that are going to
come out of this um i hope for simon
certainly for me personally um it's
great to be back here definitely for
simon's yeah so welcome sandy thank you
i am so
you know i'm pleased this punch and that
you agreed and and that
we had the
insight to ask you thank you well i
remember was in this room that you said
hey i have kind of an unusual question
for you and you floated the id and i was
like
yeah that sounds like a lot of fun so it
struck me right away as a is a an
exciting opportunity and to be honest i
didn't think about it before we were
just chatting and then i was thinking
myself this could work
let's ask her well i appreciate your
all right to do it
wonderful welcome thank you thank you